hello everyone
my name is cinfi and i'm incredibly
honored to be a part of
pi data global this year
and so a little bit about myself i
am a data engineer or who is working in
singapore
and today i will be sharing with you
about
how to speed up your data processing by
making use of parallel and experience
programming in the context of
data science so
okay now so
if you'd like to follow if you'd like to
keep in touch with me
on twitter or like something online
you could find me in the following like
social media
so to start the first to start this talk
i'll talk about about me so
i'm jingling and i'm a data engineer at
st engineering
before that my background is in
aerospace engineering and computational
modeling
and since i'm a data engineer and i do a
lot more
data transformation and manipulation
as i am a frequent user of the pandas
library
and as a way of giving back to the
community
i contribute to the pandas
and if you can if you read some of the
documentation
you might be able to see one of my
contributions
and before the pentaly situation
i do volunteer as a mentor
a big data ex boy however we conduct
data engineering workshops to
equip data professionals with the skills
to to improve their data engineering
skill sets
and as a data engineer in a data
analytics team
a typical data science workflow is as
follows
but first we extract raw data from the
source
and after which we need to process the
raw data into a suitable form
that the data scientists can use to
train their models which is the third
step
after the model has been trained
according to certain metrics and so on
that's where we evaluate the model in
terms of the performance
and then when it's ready we will look at
how they
will deploy the model so extract process
train evaluate deploy
it seems simple right well
not really because there are bottlenecks
in the data science projects
one of the bottom lines that you could
face would be probably the lack of data
if you have lack of data you probably
need to spend more time on your data
collection
so a more common situation would be that
the data that you collect would be
probably of poor quality
it will be that you could have missing
values
or that maybe you might need a little
bit
more standardization your data
but that's where we need to go through
data processing
so when we're talking about processing
that's where i will need to mention
about the 80 20 data science that i know
so in 1820 the outside there must states
that about 80 of the time it's actually
spent in data processing and
pretty much anything that is not
not conducting analytics and training
your models
right yeah so yeah
80 20 doesn't sound too bad but
sorry to burst your bubble but in
reality it is actually closer to 90 10.
so you actually end up spending a lot
more time
on data processing and not really so
much time
on getting insights from your data
so i mean okay so
as a data science team
it's expected that most of us use python
in our workflows
so we will look at data processing in in
python
so when we first learned about python
one of the first things we learned
is for loops but
the problem with for loops in python is
that even though python
is built on top of c
python for loops are run on the
interpreter and are not compiled
hence in terms of speed it is
significantly slow
compared with running a forward on c
so let's look at how we
write the four loop and python first we
initialize a list
and then for each iteration we will need
to append the value
onto the list so
if i am if i am running the iteration
100 times
that means that i will have to load the
append function
100 times and append the element to
this hundred times now it can be
a bit slow
oh what other better way to do about it
then that's why so that is how
in python we have the concept of this
comprehensions
the the thing about these computations
is that
it is slightly faster than for loops and
the main advantage is that
with the use of these combinations
there's no need to call it a pen
function
iteration so
if so in contrast if a followed survive
for each iteration i will have
to call the open of i have to call the
append function as an
object that is a feature
of the list a list
so imagine that for every iteration
from 1 to 100 i will need
to load the append function as an object
100 times but then for the list
compressions it's not
it's already there and you don't need to
load that function
hundred times hence it saves
the time in terms of right right at time
saves the time in terms of like
generating a list of values that you
need
without the repetitive process
um everything lists corporations is good
and all for typical operations
involving lists but then for the 12th
data
we typically handle in their science
projects they can tend to be
multi-dimensional with a lot of columns
and so on
so hence the preference is to use pandas
which is optimized for in-memory
analytics
using concept of data frames which is
capable of
storing multiple columns in
a more presentable manner
however the problem with 10 does is that
but when dealing with large data sets
that are more than one gigabyte or
in the scale of tens of hundreds of
gigabytes
it will change to run into performance
and of memory issues
so plus
10 dust is actually designed for
in-memory analytics so it is not really
designed and intended for out of core
use cases
so the first thing that we will think
about
is you know since the leader is too
large
to fit into a core it's not suitable for
pandas yeah why not actually
plot faster i mean big data right
like well it's not so
straightforward because when we talk
about using a spark cluster
it involves distributed computing and
when we talk about distributed computing
it will involve communication overhead
that means you're trying you're trying
to communicate between
independent machines across the network
so six spa cluster for example typically
the swat cluster we will have a three
compute nodes
but then if we want to be able to run
those three compute
nodes and synchronize the workflow
and distribute them accordingly then
each node in the spot cluster will have
to communicate with each other such that
they will know like what's the state of
each of the nodes
and when then they move on to the next
step
so i submit like no when i send a
whatsapp message
from singapore and i'm trying to send it
over to somebody in the u.s
and maybe whatsapp they do have like
those multiple servers and stuff
but they need to communicate with each
other so that's
the reason why even when i said i was a
message
and and then i and the receiver is
in the u.s it would take some
a bit of time for the precipice to be
able to receive my message
so that is the communication overhead
that i'm talking about
and it's not just about the
communication overhead that
by influencer decision to use a spot
cluster
it is also the concept of a small big
data problem
so what is small big data so okay
so this concept of small big data is
inspired by the small big data manifesto
that talks about
data that looks large but it's not
really big data
so if you would like to find out more
about what other ways to handle small
big data you could check out eternal
store
on small big data at python 2020 which
you can find on youtube
so just so to put it in simple terms
small bit data means that the data
is too big to fit in memory however
it is not large or diverse enough to
justify the use of a spark cluster
and so if we have this in between
scenario whereby
it doesn't really make sense to your
spot cluster and then if i use pandas
i'm gonna run off my run off memory and
what can i do so that's this
intermediate
solution that we have
that it's something like distributed
processing but not
really it's called parallel processing
so what is parallel processing
and so i am so pretty we don't really
unless i really like to
look at long definitions and read
through
whole bunch of words so let's illustrate
um example using food
okay so in singapore right we have those
yakun
kayatos so let's imagine that i work at
a cafe
which sells toast something like
a sick of difficulty over breakfast with
coffee
soft white eggs and
kaya butter toast now i'm not super
concerned about my software eggs because
i can just put them in the right
temperature and then this at the
timeline that's it
and it doesn't really take a lot of time
but but probably the
cake i mean it was paying more attention
to the coffee
and the toast so that's the focus of
what i'm going to talk about
so task one is that i like to toast 100
slices of bread
so some of the assumptions that i make
is that number one i'm using single
slice toasters
two each slice of toast takes two
minutes to make
three i'm assuming that there's no
overhead time
even though in rarity there will be such
slight
overhead time when i am going between
toes
before if i'm talking about
looking at sequential processing i have
100 slices of bread
i feed them one by one to a processor
in this case a toaster or we can also
call it a worker
and after feeding my slices of bread one
by one
through a water poster
i get 100 slices of toast
and let's talk about execution time to
complete this process
in a sequential manner is 200 minutes
imagine zone in summary 100 tons
for 200 minutes using sequential
processing
i require a better way of doing it same
thing
we have 100 slices of toes
but instead of feeding their one by one
through our toaster
this time we split them into
four batches of 25 toast each
after that we feed
them and fit them through
four toasters so for each batch
of for each bed we will feed them
through
a toaster
and then after which we get
100 sizes doctors but
instead of feeding them one by one the
task is
executed using a pole of
four toaster sub processors such that
each posting sub process runs in
parallel
and independently from each other
so what this means is that in the case
whereby i have a toaster that
burns out or breaks down i will still
have three other toasters
which are not affected by the faulty
toaster
so that's what i mean by independently
from each other
and after that the output of each
toasting process
is consolidated and returned
as an overall output which may or may
not be ordered
but but the bell processors
and you don't really care so much about
the order
so it doesn't really matter so if you
are looking at the sub process you have
to
you need to be sure that the order
doesn't really matter
and for the parallel processing process
the execution time is going to be 100
totals
two minutes metals and divided across
four toasters
which adds up to about 15 minutes and
that
is equivalent to a speed up of four
times
and now we've covered parallel
processing let's
talk about what is synchronous versus
asynchronous execution
so what do you mean by a synchronous
so let's illustrate it with another
example using
coffee now
in the cafe so i like to brew coffee and
some assumptions that i make
that i can do other stuff for making
coffee because
i just leave it to drip and all and i
can do other stuff
second assumption is that one coffee
maker to make one cup of coffee
and three each cup of coffee
takes five minutes to make
but if you are looking at a synchronous
mode of execution
what we do is that first we brew a cup
of coffee
on the coffee machine
and after the coffee is done we toast
two slices of bread after that
and then went out and then we get two
thousand one coffee
as a coffee set and the total execution
time
will be 9 minutes so if we imagine that
we would like to have 100 sets
that's going to take 900 minutes so this
a bit too much time so how can we
improve the process
now if we look at asynchronous execution
what we can do is that while we're
bringing the coffee
we can do all the stuff so why not
make some toast
so what they would look like instead
while i brewed coffee i could actually
make two
slices of toast and
the total execution time in this mode of
execution
will be five minutes and that is almost
that is pretty much shaving the
execution time by
almost half which is a good thing right
i'm doing multiple times at the same
time
so it looks so good right if i do
if i execute in parallel i will be able
to get
speed up if i can do things
asynchronously
or i'm waiting for something i can do
something else so it sounds like a good
idea right
now parallelism is awesome right
so if you can infer from my this slide
the question is when is it a good idea
to go for parallelism
is it always a good idea or
is it a good idea to simply just
buy or rent a 256 core processor and
then paradise
oil course and then expecting a 256
times speed up
is it really that good turns out
not really because there are some
practical considerations that we need to
think about
when we are paralyzing our codes the
first
and very important question that we
consider is
the code already optimized because
sometimes you might need rethinking
approach
such as using list compressions or map
functions instead of relying on for
loops for array iterations
another important thing to consider
would be your problem architecture
because the nature of the problem limits
how successful parallelization can be
because if your problem consists of
processes
which depend on each other's outputs
which we call
data dependency or
maybe your problem in consists of
intermediate results
whereby you have task dependency
and maybe not so what do i mean by data
dependency versus task dependency
so data dependency is whereby i am
trying to make
coffee toast and then i need
coffee as an ingredient to be able
to make my coffee tones so
in this case in this case
there is data dependency because the
output that means the copy
from the previous process is going to be
my input for the next process
and i can't really parallelize that
right
then we talk about task dependency it
means that
whether this particular process can run
would depend on the state of the
pre-resources
so let's say whereby if
i have a sink right and i want to wash
my cups
but then i also need to wash other
things but the problem is that i need to
finish washing my cups because i can
wash other things
so that's what i mean by task dependency
that means that you need to have a
completed state
for a particular task before you can
move on to the next task
so in that case it's going to be a bit
more complicated
to parallelize your workflow
and on top of that we also need to
consider that
there are overheads in parallelism
which can be summed up by m dell's law
states that there will always be parts
of the world that cannot be parallelized
all right we need to emphasize this
again there will always be parts of the
world that cannot be parallelized
and that is because when we want to
initiate
a parallelism workflow there will always
be the initialization process
that cannot be parallelized and there
will also be the consolidation process
that
also cannot be paralyzed so you can't
exactly parallelize
everything and
on top of that we also need to consider
the extra time required for coding and
debugging
parallelized code since that will lead
to
increased complexity in terms of
managing your code
and on top of this complications we also
need to consider that there will still
be some level of system overheat
including communication overheat because
for in the context of parallelism you
are
communicating you may even though you
may be communicating
within a compute you're still
you still need to communicate between
between the cause in a compute so
there will still be some communication
overhead although not
as severe as that of distributed
computing
and then so enter's law can actually be
illustrated by an equation
but let's focus more on the implications
of anders law
now emphasis law states that the
theoretical speed up
is determined by the fraction of code
that can be parallelized
note that it is a theoretical speed up
so there might be some
practical considerations that might
affect the actual speeder
now if there are no parallel parts then
their speed up is effectively zero
but if all parts are parallel then your
speed is going to be
equivalent to the number of calls which
can go up to infinity
but as we think about as i mentioned
earlier that
is not entirely possible so
we need to we need to understand
that speed up is actually limited by a
fraction of the work
that is not paralyzable and this will
not
improve even with infinite number of
processes
so which means even if i buy a 256
core instance
it's not going to help so much if i
speed up is going to be limited by how
much i can paralyze in the first place
i'm going to talk about parallelism
there are two types of parallelism that
we need to think of
so one will be multi-processing whereby
the system
allows executing multiple processes
at the same time using multiple
processes
for multi-trading it is the case whereby
the system executes
multiple threads of sub processors
at the same time within a single
processor
so you can so the difference will be on
on multiple processors and multiple
tracks in a single processor
and and because of how
they are being executed 40 processing is
better for processing large volumes of
data
whereby you can run multiple processes
to run the signature data
but for monthly trading it is best
suited for io of blocking operations
and what's the case some constitutions
that we need to consider about
parallelism
in that data processing tends to be
more compute intensive hence
the switching between threats actually
become increasingly inefficient
if we have a more complete intensive
workflow
and top of that we also need to consider
that
there's the global interpreter lock in
c python which does not allow parallel
track execution
for very good reasons because you don't
really want
parallel like you don't really want like
changes to we make on prior threats and
then you have
conflict right so
in that case um how do i do
parallel and asynchronous in python when
i'm not i mean what i'm doing is going
to be a data processing workflow
it's not going to be some machine
learning by buy
i can just leverage on like the machine
learning library framework which
has their own implementation of
multi-processing so what do i do
now this brings me to like something
that is independent python
which is the concurrent of futures
module
so the concurrent futures module is a
high level
api for launching a synchronous parallel
task
and is introduced in python 3.2 as an
abstraction layer
over the multi-processing module volume
and what what this module offers
is two months of execution the trackpool
executor for asynchronous multi trading
and process for executing for
asynchronous multi-processing
so the difference between the two can
actually be
looked at at this particular library
whereby the process for executable is
affected by the chunk size
while tranquil executor is not affected
by the translation
if we look at process four recipient and
triple executor and compare them
processbook executor uses the
multi-processing volume which sites that
the gl
while the thread tool executes subject
the gl and is not truly concurrent as
the module name suggests
and submits in concurrent takes an input
like the function and the input
arguments and it returns a futures
object that
represents the execution of the function
so it's the execution
well for the map function it takes this
input
from the function the list and it
returns an iterator that use the results
so it's like an iterator okay so
let's look at some case studies above so
in this case study
we are querying data from the data.sg
and the response is a json format and we
need to get the data
so first i initialize the modules and i
initialize the api request task and use
the trading module to monitor the track
execution
after which i initialized my job and
then i compare using list comprehensions
so for list corporations it's going to
take 16.3 minutes
but if i use the thread for executor
with 40 trades
i'm going to get a 20.9 times speed up
of
of resulting in 46.83 seconds
and if we look at the image processing
which is more compute intensive
we have this use case whereby like the
image in the data set of different
dimensions so
we need to standardize the dimensions to
fit into the machine learning models
so similarly we initialize the modules
initialize image resize use the use os
of that pid to monitor the process
execution
and then we and in this case we are
processing 1500 images
and then then we do a comparison
when i use map it's about 29.59 seconds
and
similarly for this comprehensions but if
we
beverage on process full executor with a
8 core instance
we get a 4.3 times speed up resulting
in 6.98 seconds for 100 images
so some key takeaways that i'd like you
to take a
take away from this talk is that not all
processors
should be parallelized because parallel
processors come with overheads
in the form of endorsed law system
overheat
integrating communication overhead and
most importantly if the cost of
rewriting your code for parallelization
out waste time savings or parallelizing
your code
maybe you should consider other ways of
optimizing your code instead
so thank you for watching my talk and
you can reach out to me and this
multiple social media platforms and
please check out my slides at github if
you would like a copy of it
thank you